I want to pull up the story because this
is this is freaky stuff man this is from
click to Houston News Guard certified
they say what's going on with Bank of
America social media users call out
Financial giant over missing money
they say social media erupts from the
everyday consumer to heavyweight
political and business figures the
financial Giants timeline was flooded
with complaints in the form of posts and
mocking memes one commenter appeared to
ask the question that everyone seemingly
wants to know what's going on with Bank
of America
apparently they were trending after many
customers discovered that money was
missing from their accounts the
concerned consumers shared their
experiences online
down detector consumer website reported
the issues happening with Bank of
America around 10 30 a.m you want to
know what's really funny
I learned this lesson very important
lesson I think everybody needs to know
do you know what your bank account is
do you want to notice do you know what
it is my guess is it's a computer
program it's a text file yeah it's a
text.txt the amount of money you have in
your bank is quite literally just input
text there's no cash there's no gold
literally nothing and I learned this the
hard way
because I bought a truck and uh paid I
we we financed it and then after a few
months I paid I went to pay off like I
paid off the whole thing
three months later I get a phone call
and they're like we're gonna repossess
your truck because you never paid the
bill I was gonna be talking about I paid
the lot I paid the whole thing off and
they're like no you didn't
both Banks my bank which I did the
transfer from and their Bank said we
have no record of where this money is my
bank said when we do the transfer out
all we do is write minus the number and
press enter and it subtracts from your
account and then they confirm our our
subtraction and they do the addition the
problem was the other bank didn't do the
plus so the money vanished disappeared
that's right completely disappeared
where'd the money go and they were like
we don't know and I'm like I don't
understand and then and then you know I
basically had a guy say to me like he
didn't say it like this but what do you
think your money in the bank is there's
no cash in there you do not have a a box
full of cash in a vault they quite
literally just type a number and press
enter yeah it's promissory notes no no
no no no no it's not it's not even a
crypto like you think with Bitcoin
there's there's there's an encryption
key behind that that at Bitcoin it
exists you could hold it there's
something there at least a string a hash
code with your bank literal nothing the
only thing that exists is The Ledger
itself
and when the when the Ledger doesn't
reflect the actual transaction it
doesn't matter because the other bank
went we don't know we don't have the
money and my bank said we don't have the
money either your money is just gone
it's so hackable that is so controllable
to think that these private companies
have secret text files that have your
money on it that they can change at will
behind the scenes or that someone else
could hack it well like at that point I
do believe crypto is more secure even
though you could lose it and it could go
to zero they're not at least diversify
your assets not necessarily in just what
you invest in but having crypto having
cash in the bank having cash at home and
like you mentioned a few days ago having
gold I mean it when things go south
let me you want to have tangible assets
just in case I'll tell you guys a story
when I was uh when I was like 20 I think
I was like 21.
my buddy overdrafts and he's like why
did I overdraft this this doesn't make
sense what happened was in Chicago there
was this big Scandal where the CTA the
the public transit was double charging
people
so we're broke he's got 30 bucks in the
bank he spends 20 bucks
then his paycheck comes in on a Friday
he should have 180 bucks instead he's
like negative 200. and he's like what
happened well apparently what happened
was the CTA double charged him putting
him negative then he got hit with
overdraft fee overdraft fee bought a
pack of gum for two dollars right stupid
so then he he accumulates all these
overdraft fees his paycheck doesn't
cover him he's trying to buy things he's
getting more and then also he's negative
and and I could be totally wrong about
this because it's been 20 years but I'm
pretty sure we go to the bank this is a
crazy story
and we're hanging out and he sits down
with this this like manager guy in a
suit and he says you know he pulls up
his his bank account he's pointing at
things he was like look look right there
like like CTA charged me three times
like that caused me to go negative then
my paycheck came in and the guy was just
like okay okay he turns them on it
around and then he starts typing stuff
in he spins it back around and it says
like negative 400 and he puts the cursor
on the negative and clicks backspace and
then says how does that look and then my
friend's like uh okay and then he was
like there you go and hit enter did
something and I'm like we were like wait
what just happened does he now have 400
bucks okay get this
the Bank closed down a few weeks later
so I have to wonder what may have
happened was this guy knew he was
getting laid off
the manager and so he was like screw
these people and just transferred money
but but I I'm almost kind of like was he
screwing with us because there's no way
he can do a hard input and just change
something I think he can they have
discretionary like a person on the phone
can be like yeah I'll overwrite your 35
charge but they only have a certain
limit that they can overwrite and then
the manager is probably like 500 per
customer per week or something you can
we used to be backed by gold I mean this
is a relatively the last hundred years
central banks Federal Reserve I'm sure
everyone watching has knowledge on that
but I mean there used to be when you
said hey I'd like to take out money they
had gold to to trade it in one one quick
note on the rat thing I actually
misinterpreted it that oh they put them
in they'll last longer I think we the
people would actually like if they're
going to put us back on we just bite
their hand a lot like I don't think I'd
go back swimming
in that tank for 60 hours
a lot of people they want to get people
to put themselves in the tank I think a
lot of people would also be like we
don't think of how many people don't
trust the CDC the FDA big for I I was
like never like that really before if
you trust the government now you haven't
been paying attention and you had your
head in uh in in the sand for the last
three years I didn't trust the
government but like I thought at least
the medical people were generally pretty
squared away let's let's add the banking
component into what's going on now with
people like there's a viral video of
people in a bank and they're like
where's our money right
think about what can happen if this
cyber event is everyone's money
disappearing what happens afterwards no
everyone then calls the government and
says I want my FDIC insured whatever and
now all of a sudden you are on your
knees in front of some government BS
being like please sir may I have another
please regulate this
industry more please exactly now we need
a central bank digital currency now we
need a universal basic income and that's
one of the perfect ways to implement
they're going to come out and they're
going to be like we don't know what
happened it was a Cyber attack the whole
the whole it's the Russians The Ledger
has gone down it was Russia who did it
what we're going to do is we're going to
give everybody five thousand dollars in
their accounts for the time being so you
can have basic Goods all the poor people
are going to be like yay and all the
rich people and all the middle class
people are going to be like my life is
being destroyed we need to put in a new
Patriot Act but this one's going to have
a dollar sign after it Patriot Act for
money
what do you guys think about Patriot Act
gold I think that the Central Bank
digital currency that they're talking
about doing is probably going to happen
at some point and it'll probably usurp
the dollar or become part of the dollar
and like a dollar bill will represent as
a token but what do you guys think about
like a United States decentralized
crypto like Bitcoin but like just backed
by you the United States government
totally decentralized what does that
mean that would get back by the threat
of being drone bombed yeah exactly
because I was like what would I say to
Congress like how do we fix the economy
I'm just grasping straws but obviously
our money used to be gold but now it's
the threat of being blown up literally
and it's all you know the money
everything is drifting electronic right
so California is kind of like a
predictor of things to come in terms of
the leftist agenda here they want your
car to be electric they want your stove
to be electric they want your money to
be purely electric why because you can
control things that are electric yeah
you have the grid and I wouldn't say
drifting I would say it's like you know
help reading yeah koreaning word so
maybe instead of it being backed by
force it would just be like Amer you can
buy American Goods with this
cryptocurrency in addition to the US
dollar and then it was DT
um yeah something like that but like
that's back I think by the dollar they
have to have dollar reserves that's
tethered like literally I think that's a
state yeah that's tether yeah that's it
stays the exact value as the dollar so
it could be but I think it would take
off and become more valuable than the
dollar just because it's digital none of
you always the power could always go out
and then you're Back to Basics where
that's why cash you could never I don't
think you'd ever should get rid of Cash
ever but I don't imagine I'll put like
trying to put those uh what do they call
those little barcodes on each dollar
bill
QRS or or I'm talking about the little
metal strips that they put in your
credit card they're like they're printed
from like foil but they can magnetically
measure where you're at and all that
track you well there's also a war on
cash and many places already have
stopped accepting it in many many
businesses as well and they don't have
the exact change for it and yeah
well I think I don't know I have to look
into that but there's a better idea
there's microchips that you could shove
up you know what and then you have to be
you know attracted uh and it's inside of
you and and they'll know that it's going
to be your transaction and you have to
be probed every time you want to use uh
you know the money and then they know
exactly it's coming from you to uh
whatever else you're buying and then
they have a perfect record and then
they'll know exactly how many taxes you
have to pay they'll know exactly what
you're buying they'll share it with all
the big uh corporations that will know
your your consumer activities which will
help them sell you better products in
China what's the libertarian solution
because the US dollar is a real status
thing like you can go to Wyoming and buy
groceries at a grocery store there with
the US dollar because the American
Military is like you better or we're
gonna and we are in control and everyone
is using the US dollar here there's
there's a reason Libertarians and and
the Ron paulers have been screaming
about the dangers of the U.S federal
reserve for so many years if you look at
Ron Paul even before the major financial
problem one of the things that he was
making arguments against is the Federal
Reserve printing money out of thin air
this was before 2008 that it has been a
staple position of many Libertarians of
many anti-statists saying hey this
creature from Jekyll Island is a big
problem because they could literally
create inflation they could create
deflation but they know what's going to
happen so they could game the market so
they are always the winners and you will
always be the loser and this is what
they've been doing for decades on
decades on decades and this is why the
Libertarians have been talking about
this because you you get rid of that
Central Bank just like Thomas Jefferson
did that he gets put on the 20 bill but
but you get rid of that you allow people
to have more freedom and you're not
controlled by the whims of banksters
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time